okay my stepmom is Filipino well she
just got my they broke up but you know
Filipinos tell it like it is oh yeah my
Filipino stepmom the first time I met
her I go hey I'm Michael and her name
coincidentally was Lex oh so the first
time I met her I go hey it's nice to
meet you how are you she goes well you
know I have
diarrhea that's a good Filipino and then
the next time it's like so Michael are
you gay yeah why would you say that well
you're 44 years old you live in Harwood
you're an actor very
single went depression yeah but I I said
that when you did park though I go how
why aren't you married yet you did ask
me that the first question I she like do
you have a girlfriend don't you ha and
you felt sad for me you said I was going
to be like paully Shore yeah I just he
no but stop don't do that it's because
of the fact that I adore this guy I
really do and I I don't want to I don't
want him to become somebody that's just
like in the 60s never had children but
as if you can't live a fully fulfilled
Life by yourself selfa I I I am looking
for oh you are okay I'm dating there's
understand your argument I used to like
well 20s and 30s you just you [__] you
haven't you have a good you know maybe
not no I no no no he just looked at me
no but you looked at me a certain way
like don't throw this [__] on me yeah
no but I just to say this this [__]
got right here he's not a closer he's
not a closer he could learn some [__]
about you know cuz you're handsome you
have your [__] together maybe his
sexuality is questioning that who knows
we don't know maybe like Mory maybe he's
like Mor maybe he's banging tons of
people and we don't know it nope maybe
he's banging tons of Phil no no George
you're a good dude yeah but what is it
what hang on yeah yeah what are you
saying that people that [__] aren't as
good as people who don't [__] no but I
just want to say that so that he doesn't
feel hurt yeah yeah he's not really a
good dude I'm just saying that yeah I'm
I'm a liar yeah yeah yeah but I got you
know he's not a [__] machine though I
don't like I used to go out all the time
I used to now I'm exhausted I'm 44 years
old I'm like work and I like to have
friends over with karaoke you guys
invited over but I don't like I used to
go out I got I want to get late I want
to meet girls and it's just exhausting
now you have your phone and you know
it's
just amazing it's just a lot so much
it's just a lot so now I just try to
like I try to find someone I could enjoy
my life with so I defitely I have been
dating I'm not going to say much more
than that don't have to say much I don't
need to say anything but you know things
are things are all right good also I
mildly stocked your Instagram and it's
because you have a dog and dogs give you
so much love that sleep with my dog yeah
yeah it doesn't incentivize you as much
to go out and go [__] hunting because
you have that kind of love at home and
honestly I could live with my animals my
whole life alone without this
[__] really yeah with four
animals I think I'm fulfilled really
yeah I mean that's why I'm dude let me
say something right now before my
girlfriend I hated animals you also
hated Bobby I hated I hated myself too I
hated myself yeah I think we all hate
ourselves in a way yeah there's not one
person in this room that probably
doesn't hate them a little bit yeah but
I I hate myself yeah but I used I'm I'm
self-conscious about my areola size yeah
what is your what's are it's pretty it's
like a um silver dollar pancake you but
you can't hate yourself for your nipples
are [__] awful I have the smallest
nipples you'll let see let me see let me
see let me check it out oh
jeez God so cute small and big so TI wow
you know but it's you know I have I have
large balls when I was
younger when I was younger I remember I
I looked at my grandfather Lou and he
had this giant bulge in his slacks and I
I looked at him I'm telling my brother I
ER he was looking at like dude what's up
with Grandpa's balls and then I heard
about elephan titis which is that's not
it but then I remember my dad he my
dad's real private we were driving back
home from New York and I'm like hey why
are Grand palo's balls so big you have
some respect for your
father your grandfather and he just has
these giant testicles and then I got
really word and I cried to my dad I go
Dad my I think my balls are big am I
gonna have am I gonna have grand paloo
balls and he was like no no no my grand
my mother who's on valum like it's not
even your real grandfather Yeah yeah
which is true he did lie to you he
wasn't grandfather oh he wasn't but my
balls aren't like that oh they're not
like that but they're pretty big though
no I mean I have I have good siiz balls
yeah because you showed us kind of a
little bit before yeah do you do you
ever hey let's not do you ever
accidentally sit on them no they're not
they're not that big then they're not
that big I do the ball Buckle routine I
used to do that and I I also want to
make amends to you baby and oh today no
it's about something that I did last
week oh tell me and I I want before I
bring it up are you sure you want to be
here for yeah he's going to be here I'm
here man might assault I'm actually the
the counselor okay good good I don't
want you to get angry you promise you
won't get angry yes I mean no I don't
promise anything I'm not going to say
then just [__] say it Bobby just
promise you won't be angry but can I
physically assault you still no you
can't touch me and phys be that's Ang no
no that's not true it could just it
could physical assault can come from
many different emotions I'm going to to
say it okay I never saw Aeros
peros you [__] whoa what's that
what's that so for for months she was
like you have to watch this movie he's
so righteous about the types all these
movies that he's seen tashir muun
kurasawa oh you've never seen the
seventh Samurai he just he sits on this
[__] high horse and he tells
everybody around him how stupid they are
for not having seen these Classics or
these movies by these directors right so
I told him I was like Hey like have you
seen Amores peros which is by um can you
say it in English though I didn't
understand Amores peros that re re the
Reven guy it's an Inu movie and he goes
oh yeah I've seen that of course I've
seen this no no so this is what she goes
she goes I know I didn't say that listen
shut the [__] up all right she goes I go
I haven't seen it and she goes goes well
you're going to watch it tonight I go I
don't want to watch it tonight I want to
do other things I want to watch
Westworld no you're watching it and I go
and so when she was in the shower right
I Wikipedia it right and I read the
synopsis right and I memorized as much
as I could and then when she came back I
cleared my history on my iPad just so
that she didn't know that I was
Wikipedia it did you look on his history
to see if he had done it so I bought no
so I bought the movie We're L sitting
next to each other and it starts I go
wait does this movie have like a dog is
a theme she goes yeah I go is this like
three or four stories combined she goes
yeah I go is the SE I go do the Second
Story have to do with like a model and
like a guy
that yeah I've seen that I saw it with
my friend Kalisto you went through the
trouble of buying the movie yeah 1999
bought yeah yeah so just I that's it
that's
incredible great wow you had it all work
out just so you couldn't sit through an
hour and a half movie that you
girlfriend who loves you I I wanted you
to say that's genius but really not
genius and you know what else I did I
said I'll watch it if you want me to she
said no you don't have to watch it now
because I I it would have I would have
enjoyed it it's such a good
movie Filipino
stutter yeah I'm sorry and I'm never
going to see it I'm never going to see
good movie well it's your loss it's my L
it's a great [__] movie oh my God
that was that man why keep in the closet
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah was somebody
knocking where's Bryce was somebody
knocking downstairs maybe to loud are we
too loud no we're not we're not way
louder than that Lou by the way it's
6:30 which is down it's it's early yeah
but I I'm not going to watch it it's
okay but are you mad at me are you mad
at me no was it funny though you know it
actually crossed my mind that you would
Wikipedia that [__] because that's
something you would do you lazy
[__] it's such a good movie watch never
seen it you know what I'll watch it not
tonight watch inu's first all right
right all right let's move on all right
but you're not mad no I'm not let me ask
you is he getting laid
tonight probably not Michael M go ahead
probably not yeah I have some old DVD
small bills if you want to buy Luther
Luther Lu I might have some of those too
though yeah do you believe that I met
her on
Tinder uh I can't believe she's
beautiful I mean not the girls aren't
beautiful who are in Tinder yeah this
clar's starting to kick in I'm allergic
to his [__] cats about to die here I
love cats oh really no are you really
are you are you like feeling it right
now I feel better I could breathe now
okay good good but before you weren't
you know starting to feel I say
something you got to be around cats to
get over it right is that what you said
to me yeah you you expose yourself
little same thing with dairy the to get
over lactose intolerance you have a
little bit of dairy every day really so
if you cut off the Dair my pants every
day how long do I have to experience
stop [__] but your farts don't even
smell so like you're winning that's true
yeah but my hand I can I tell him yeah
yeah yeah I have um I have um OCD no I
have my left foot is a disaster I have
severe foot
fungi I didn't want to laugh but you did
first do you really you really do and at
one point is that true oh I had it in my
fingers because I scratched my foot and
it went inside her vagina he gave me
jock itch essentially inside vagina so
that's tragic it's tragic it was tragic
for me did do you wear a sock when you
guys go to
bed one sock on that foot no but he's
not allowed to touch any part of my body
with his left foot like he knows this
it's a disaster it's a disaster is it
what does it look like it's fine have
you you're not going you're not going to
look at it it's fine but not great it's
not great no it's not great like uh
Daniel D Lewis it used to be worse my
left foot yeah it's like that is it like
the I mean at one time my left foot was
so bad that when I was on Mad a long
time it's been bad for many years I
showed Ike Baron haltz my left foot and
he took three steps back and he made a
noise like like that like it was bad
yeah you could see mold does it does it
smell at all yeah like what does it
smell
like like are we talking Bri no I'm
talking no no I'm talking worse than
Brie I'm talking about like can test to
this uh yeah
something dead rodent and you can't get
rid of this no I can no I can I what the
[__] are we talking let me explain to
you so I got him a big box of this
medication called lzo and it was really
effec why is it got to be called Loser
poor guy's got a footb guy and he's got
to use a product called loso hey loser
how about some L over
what and I put it on it worked and it
turns out he doesn't want it to work cuz
it's an activity for him to scratch and
peel his foot every day I missed it he
missed his foot I missed it yeah that's
really like that's therape that's
therapy stuff I love it I love it have
you talked to your therapist about this
I don't have a therapist I don't need
one you don't need one no but I uh this
is your therapy yeah I enjoy peeling it
God I enjoy I enjoy scratching it deep
scratches it's it yeah when I'm in the
spa that's what my that's my ritual yeah
wait so you go in the spa I go to the
the top tier of the steam room right and
I put my foot out there you know I go
late so there's no one around and I when
I when it when hot gets it gets itchier
when it's hot yeah my foot and I just
take my finger and I deep scratch it it
feels so good does it get infected and I
don't know I'm not a
doctor have you guys seen this no it's
it but we know that it's a thing in fact
who brought it up to me to my left foot
who did the that [__] up Guy what's
his name what oh um Ed um Asner Ed Asner
Big Ed Asner it's so funny that you you
mention Tom Arnold because I did a pilot
with Tom Arnold Tom Arnold and Ed Asner
and where we own a hardware store right
and Ed Asner and I were like best
friends right so and I remember then
going he him talking to him for hours
about my left foot and then years later
we did um Tom Green's podcast video
podcast and he was on it and you would
think this 80-year-old man is probably
you know we we thought Bobby thinks he's
like somewhat scile already yeah but he
wasn't scile enough he talked about your
foot he remembered years later this is
about eight years later he remembered
that's the only thing he remember get
your foot away from me he says are you
serious yeah yeah he remembered that's
how don't you guys kind of want to see
it in a really weird way no you're not
going to see it ever ever is it maybe
one day show to her what about yeah what
about this what about this you set up
the Bruce Campbell thing and you'll be
one of the only guys in Hollywood that
see my left
foot the I I'll do it you will I want to
see it you have you need to see it his
nails on that foot are very polished
though they're shiny on your right it's
algae oh yeah it's algae makes it shiny
is it in uh thing is a genetic thing
it's not well first of all no you don't
get genetic athletes foot well I thought
maybe that you guys had a propensity or
no not what you guys Koreans gos is why
you say not you guys no is that what you
want to say no that's not what I say I'm
saying oh my God is this is how you get
thrown as you're a filthy you're act
like a filthy Jew right
now all right and stop acting that way
okay I apologize so um yeah producer
left [__] that's not my producer he's my
henchmen his his bladder I'll play this
game with I'll play this game with you
okay so go ahead when you look in the
mirr I want you to pretend I'm the
mirror okay mhm but I want you to
articulate what you're thinking while
you're looking at yourself in the and I
want you to be honest I only be trying
to be Comedian Bobby Lee all right I'm
going to be real I'm going to be real
I'm going to um so let's wait let's just
when I wake up okay so I wake up right
you're the mirror but I'm not in the
bathroom yet okay so I wake up I'm going
to tell you my I want to tell you my
thoughts and I'm going to be really real
okay did I buy a Red Bull do I I think I
did [__] get up you got to get up you
got to get up so I get up I wander into
the kitchen and I get this sugar-free
red bow that I bought this and I just
down it so I could just get up first
thing in the morning you down a Red Bull
yeah and then I go to the bathroom and
you're the mirror I
look I yeah hi hello I say hi to myself
right don't smile if you dude I'm tell
you right now no stop I'm going to do it
again restart the whole thing no I'm not
going to start I'm going to go to the
mirror again again B would just say
please don't smile because that's you're
not being because I don't believe you
that that's what I say you really say
that you say hey I do I do yes I do yeah
so all right then if you you smile I I
might get really offended can I put this
over my face no no you cannot that's not
fair because it's not acting can you act
you took classes you're in [__] TV
show fine I won't [__] laugh I'm
going to really try not to laugh don't
try to milk this Stu going to milk it
all right so I I keep your eye contact
with no no no what I do when I look when
your eyes go up to me
that's you have to stay me I know but
I'm going to you said to be real so I
don't just look into the mirror I go
from bottom up you start from your feet
no I just kind of look from here and I
go up so go ahead but you got to open
your eyes though I don't want to you
have just you can smile that's fine try
not to but won ready ready so I go I
go
hello fck
you
I
hello
hello oh [__] all right all right all
right all right all right um no I I look
at my I look at myself and I go okay
hold on all right I go um I this is what
I think I go a lot of times I go I'll be
honest no the mirror anymore a lot of I
think um it it kind of oh [__] I'm Asian
oh come on I'm literally like it it's
not like a conscious thought but there's
a little bit like oh I'm
Asian it's weird why don't you turn it
into even more positive I'm Asian I'll
probably live longer than most people no
it's a good thing when I say that I'm
saying yeah well no yeah cuz you'll live
longer cuz you eat healthier yeah but I
don't need to use that second thing
because I like just being Asian yeah
okay so I look and I go I go your
mustache is cool and then I go um I like
your hair
and you're a little fat but I it's a
charactery look right you look
charactery now right and um you don't
look almost
50 you know I can I look in the mirror I
go oh my God I'm almost 50 but I don't
look it and then I and and then then
that's it but it's not negative I'm
trying to think of honestly what I do
when I walk in the I you know I honestly
you go ahead yeah on the mirror I wake
up go ahead wake up yeah okay
I look in the mirror and I said can they
replace under your eyes oh maybe I
should replace you look really tired man
[__] you're 45 years old man you're
halfway to death you don't have much
time left you don't sleep well you've
been doing Xanax quarter Xanax to sleep
every night you got to stop that
melatonin don't work
though melatonin I can't drink a Red
Bull cuz I'll die Bob's going to die
early from drinking all that Red Bull so
don't do that you're okay looking I
don't like your facial hair cuz it's
like wow cuz you got you go through that
whole thought process you're 45 yeah
yeah I'm 45 both of you Benjamin I'm not
I'm not say like I'm not the I'm like I
think we all have a little depression
right you have depression yeah what what
do you get depressed about my nipples
that's right we've talked about that can
I see them real quick ah [__] I've done
I didn't shave them Bobby so they were
big yeah oh yeah they're not that bad no
they are they are they they're [__]
terrible it comes to like yeah when it
comes to like a nipple competition like
in terms of originality that you would
win yeah yeah I mean if they're like my
nipples right here yeah your and my
nipples could be candy very similar like
if a candy was shaped like our [__]
nipples yeah what would the candy be
called um yellow pinks yellow pink
mine's yellow yours are pink right so we
be a candy together banana a banana star
apple right the pH Brown [__] come on
down and get some brown [__] in the
Philippines our M&M's are called nips oh
very SE and I I I have the jingle still
memorized which is yeah and then we
color all the flowers and we paint the
trees the sweet and delicious look at
all those bees when I want fun I grab a
bag of nips and make a
rainbow [__]
Li that's amazing you can hear the end
of it and he goes nips nips yeah shout
out shout out to the Philippines Wow all
I can remember is 588 to 300 I just I I
can imagine just like a big bag full of
Japanese
people some ni you know but uh I love
those old Jingles though right there was
um rice aroni the San Francisco treat
that was a good one and here's another
one we're in Hawaii right sing I was
singing I was singing the the quicker
picker uper
oh what was the one that was singing in
um oh CN pure can sugar that's the one
is it I don't know yeah that was the
ending of it I think we're too young for
that yeah was 70s ' 70s I used to by men
oh yeah remember that one by
men I always want to the guy the stoner
in the back who was like we needed
something for men in here guys guy in
the back is
like yeah John what is
it
by yeah break yeah break we should do
one with tiger belly how about the
bisco I can't do there was no there's no
clink there's no clink I forget it yeah
yeah think of one for Tiger
belly what tiger tiger for the Vlog
everybody come up with one right now go
ahead the Vlog one that I came that I
came up with it's tiger belly that's a
good one go ahead what about you it's
I'll just do the same thing it's tiger
belly
it's that was very Japanese that was
very like I didn't mean to be Japanese
very Japanese do you have eyebrows UNH
helpful advice with Bobby Kila and
inside of you with Michael
rosenb this next question uh was
interesting uh hey hey tiger B why do I
keep lying and creating stories and
situations just to create conversation I
also have a tendency to change things
that happen in real life to make them
more dramatic expensive or cool I really
hate it immediately after I regret it I
wish I didn't do this cuz I value
honesty I'm a fraud help me my name is
Eric that that's my whole
life every single thing I've ever said
in my life is an
embellishment well no this person like
lies a lot right mhm read that first
part again why do I keep lying and
creating stories and situations just to
create conversations ly different from
embellishing that goes from that's
that's back to Childhood she didn't have
trust around her as a child her parents
she probably didn't trust you probably
didn't TR trust uh people around her you
got to be around you got to be honest
man okay um say to me hey did you see
the movie um you see the movie um
Dunkirk you say Dunkirk did you see
movie dun yeah it was good yeah I I do
that all the time I hang on I do that
when someone when I don't want to get in
a conversation some goes oh did you hear
have you heard that song cuz I know
they're going to play it for me yeah
that's different that's like saying I
don't want to hear your [__] s yeah
but you're still lying that's not a lie
that's a that's a soft
lie Li we all do it out there right guys
we're always like oh my God have you
heard that news th by sublim Sublime and
you're like Sublime like oh yeah no no
I've heard it or I do that trick dead I
do this trick too is he I I do this
trick too rest in peace if I'm I'm at
the Grove or a mall and I see a group of
people coming up to take photos I do
this and I pretend I'm talking on the
phone wow that's rude they're your fans
I think this is a person I do that I
never would do that to my fans Michael
you've never done anything man of the
people you've never done anything like
that I I think I probably have something
like that if I saw like I was eating or
I was eating something or doing
something I would just but were you in a
situation me with The Comedy Store where
someone was talking to me and you didn't
get me out of the situation oh my God
that was the most uncomfortable [__]
thing ever dude did we talk about that I
tried to help you there's this dude who
came up to Bobby well this [__] guy
we were talking Bobby we're in the
middle of a conversation about life yeah
yeah and then he comes he comes to talk
to me and I keep looking at Michael like
you can get me out of the situation now
by doing a number of things Bob Bobby
was literally doing this the guy was
next to him like right here talking to
him Bobby
Go I mean if it wasn't if if that
doesn't spark something in his mind that
says this guy doesn't want to talk to me
there's something CRA why didn't you do
nothing will work I tried I tried to do
an armpit fart I
thought I was like I was like this is
what you do okay this is what you do you
and I hanging out May Gil you come talk
to him hey really big fan Smallville
thanks man I appreciate that man wait
wait no no offense yeah my uncle just
died and I I have to talk I have to talk
to him about this situation yeah dude
sorry his uncle just died sorry love
Smallville oh thanks so much yeah but I
got I'm no offense I'm so sorry he
actually died on set of
Smallville yeah why you laughing I cuz
have a time I have a hard time believing
that your uncle I have a hard time Bing
your uncle died on his show set from 10
years ago yeah but he did all right
that's how it happened by the way I I I
thought I did something I thought I said
no you didn't I thought I did this I did
this once you don't remember this I
went yeah you did do that you did do
that and I thought that would be enough
that never worked in the history of that
but hang on it was literally like right
be that guy you're you're me yeah yeah
Bobby I love Matt TV really
thanks yeah anyways can I get your
autograph what
I thought that would work yeah it's yeah
I thought it work you know what I also
hate at The Comedy Store what that
you're there every hey I'm producing a
movie right they come up to you and go
oh cool what's the
company well I don't really had have a
script yet and there's no company I want
you're going to be the star of it can I
get your
email sure what yeah I wish I nothing
yeah that that does happen a lot so
delusional people go hey man we're
working on some project right now e
perfect as the lead we're talking about
Chan I'm
tting yeah yeah they drop a bunch of
names and they a bunch of names were
talking to them I'm like oh great wow is
this for Sony or uh is Marvel doing this
and they're like well we're going to
eventually talk to those guys you know
what Skyler Stone did to me what he
emailed me hey man you want to be in a
[__] motion
picture I love that term
motion
picture right and I go what are you
talking about who says would you like to
be in a in a major studio
production so I go yeah he's like me you
he named crystalia a couple of other
names right he goes I just need you on
board right now it's legit the casting
director of The Producers they all legit
right and then two weeks later Chris
comes up to me and goes did you get the
email from that
movie I go no and I run to Skyler I I
didn't want you but then don't [__]
don't [__] email me you know who did
that I love him to death nah he sort of
did it but that happens a lot it does
happen a lot where people go hey dude
I'm doing this oh my God I'm going to
shoot this movie in a month with [__]
so and so and you would be dude you're
perfect for the part you know I'm going
to text so and so right now yeah dumb
ass who feels like I'm just like what's
the word uh what's the word for begging
or not begging but uh feeling like
you're uh needy not needy uh uh
desperate thank you for all helping me
out for one easy word no but I was like
like a month L I'm like hey whatever
happened with that one cool project you
were talking about
yeah oh yeah dude it's not going to work
yeah yeah why did I even do that why did
why did you do that I don't know I found
I felt because it sounded cool I've done
that before too yeah I felt like an
idiot yeah yeah they didn't want me
either Bobby we didn't answer this kid
lying I know just one last thing though
I like talking about stuff like this and
then um and then they get afraid and
then my friend Nick did a movie this
year not schwartzon okay cuz that's who
told me my friend n goes it's five lines
it's an independent movie that's
disrespectful right he goes you need a
read though for me [__] I got to read
for you five lines five lines and he
goes yeah yeah I go I'm not reading he
go well you're not in the movie I wasn't
in the movie so what yeah but my point
is is that if you if you're doing a
movie I understand I tested for your
show you went right to test no I did two
auditions I I went and read for you once
yeah that was it's a real TV it's a real
TV show though right pass there's
there's real and I tried to just go I
understand that no but I understand that
so I read for you and that's it's a real
thing you have to do it okay but if you
were producing a movie
I heart for you period and you had five
lines you would just give it to me I
assume and you wouldn't do it I would do
it okay good it's good to know yeah cuz
you directed some movies right yeah mov
I've never even not well hang on hang on
hang on the the movie was about not in
four no there are four guys and but I
went to your house like look at the
trailer well hang on day but these are
based on real people they were based on
real people a black guy and uh fat guy
and guy and they were all directed a
movie yes but there wasn't an Asian guy
there's only four people in the whole
[__] movie dude with lines you would
have come there for like one line that's
beneath you I would not do that to my
friend hey Bobby will you fly to Indiana
Coach on like [__] media air for uh
to do one line and you say hey can I get
you guys a beer would you want to do
that you want to real no but I would you
know what I like you know what I like
say this I would like to just can you do
me this and I was like I can't do it
because that's what you would say I'd
have to ask but I'm K i' have to go Kila
hey can you get saying now that if I if
I was I was dirting a movie three we
turnover if I Wasing a movie I would
just I call you for a line I shot in
Indiana anyway so the guy I shot in
Indiana so the guy don't lie I swear to
God no I'm talking about the guy the guy
don't lie mhm his name is Eric that was
don't lie is his name don't lie